A number of other useful helper methods are available there too.
And it's a good idea to look up the documentation about each of them.
One of the most useful properties is .constructor,
which makes it easy to tell what function was used to create a certain object.
Like all properties,
.constructor actually points to a different object that's stored elsewhere.
People frequently confuse the object prototype with this
constructor function used to make all objects.
So let's visualize the two in different boxes for
a moment as a reminder of the way it's really laid out inside your computer.
Whenever you ask an object about its .constructor property,
the object most likely doesn't have a local .constructor property, so
the prototype chain gets consulted.
The .constructor property on the object prototype points to the constructor
function for making object and so that object is provided as the result.